en los últimos 20 años me he convencido
que el alma se pasa su vida brillando
y que ese es el significado de nuestras
vidas encontrar la manera de dejar salir
el salud
pero es el contexto nuestro entorno lo
que nos rodea lo que se encarga de
bloquear esa luz nuestros problemas las
finanzas el tráfico la violencia las
noticias todo eso que parece adversidad
nos da la oportunidad de tener un
propósito en nuestras vidas dejar salir
esa luz que tenemos en el alma y eso que
estamos viendo ahí somos nosotros
los seres de luz
postrados en un planeta un punto hermoso
y azul brillante en el espacio que si lo
único que tenemos y entre todos esos
estoy yo
y ser yo es que quien ve esta foto y me
conoce diga clásico y sin camisa
ahí está mi nombre es jesús salvador
están mis lenguajes y mis experiencias
está mi tiempo
esa foto es de junio de este año cuando
estaba terminando el ramadán el ramadán
es algo que hacen los musulmanes cada
año en el noveno mes de su calendario
para agradecer y para sentir empatía con
los que menos tienen se trata de un
ayuno de sol a sol no comer nada ni
tomar nada desde que sale el sol hasta
que se mete en monterrey el sol sale a
las seis y media de la mañana en junio y
se mete a las ocho y media de la noche
en promedio sin comer y sin beber agua
lo que hice es ser porque me parecía una
manera de agradecer de forma radical lo
que acababa de vivir porque en los
premios 18 meses tuve la oportunidad de
visitar 20 países de vivir seis meses
dentro de nasa de conocer a personas
como bill gates o jack ma de alí babá de
crear conexiones humanas tan potentes
que me hicieron sentir muy valiente y lo
más importante que me hacían darme
cuenta que había encontrado el propósito
que estaba siendo empleado del universo
que tenía una cosa y una razón por la
cual vivir y durante el ramadán
permite consolidar todas estas buenas
experiencias y toda esta energía ya
aunque fue bastante difícil porque
algunos días me levantaba y ya había
salido el sol y sabía que tenían que
pasar 24 horas sin tomar nada ni comer
nada pero ahí me ayudó a consolidar ya
darme cuenta que lo más difícil es
entendernos como seres sociales porque
lo más complicado no era aguantar el
hambre y la sed era entender y hacer
entender aquellos con los que iba a
comer mis amigos mis familiares en
comidas de negocio y hoy no come
fue tan difícil el ramadán que me ayudó
a entender las pequeñas cosas y el valor
detrás de ellas yo el último día justo
previo a esa mañana me fui a dormir con
la sola esperanza de ver al sol y
disfrutar de una taza de café
me sentía pleno sentía que tenía
propósito y al mismo tiempo en casa
crecía mi pequeña amanda mi niña de 3
años contrastando con mis hermosas
pasiones y esa sensación del corazón que
se salía del pecho estaba en mis peores
temores una niña que tomaba un avión de
juguete y decía mira papi donde tú vives
o que se despertaba en las madrugadas y
me veía a un lado y se asustaba porque
no estaba acostumbrada a ver a papá y
se dice que aún en los peores escenarios
de pobreza de criminalidad y violencia
no se comparan con el peor de los
temores que es dejar de pertenecer a la
propia familia
en contraste con todo mi amor por mi
causa y conocer a todas estas
celebridades que les digo estaban mis
peores temores mi pequeña niña creciendo
sin la voz de papá me preguntaba cómo es
posible que esté yo enfrentando a esto y
en palabras de jonathan jair en su libro
de la hipótesis de la felicidad entendí
que somos seres divididos nuestras
pasiones y nuestros temores él lo narra
como un infante y un jinete un elefante
que es nuestro corazoncito la parte
emocional que se mueve un piloto
automático que yo veía cara a cara en el
ramadán cuando me encontraba habituado
preparando en un café diciendo que estoy
haciendo y un jinete que es nuestros
pensamientos lo que creemos que sabemos
tomar decisiones que cree saber a dónde
va pero en realidad el elefante tiene
suficiente poder de voluntad desea
mahoma que dios creó a los ángeles de
intelecto sin sensualidad ya las bestias
de sensualidad sin intelecto y al ser
humano de ángeles y de bestias y allí
entendí que mis pasiones y mis temores
soy yo y de esta interconexión es en
donde está esa plenitud que hace que
salga a la luz del alma
y así ha sido siempre una búsqueda
constante por ser auténticos por
encontrarnos y aceptarnos en temores y
en pasiones les cuento una breve
historia hace 14 millones de años así
era el planeta este el universo perdón
era materia de antimateria super
interconectados fuerte fuerte fuerte
fuerte caliente caliente caliente
caliente que cuando se empezó a enfriar
un poquito
nos dividimos por primera vez nos
hicimos polvo de estrellas y todos
estamos hecho de esto a partir de ahí
vino la primera buena interconexión
tuvimos la suerte que el planeta es el
único que tenemos quedó tan cerca del
sol pero tan perfectamente distanciado
que nuestros mares no se evaporaron ni
tampoco se congelaron incluso lo más
interesante el hidrógeno que es un
elemento altamente explosivo y el
oxígeno que alimenta el fuego adjuntar
se extingue en el fuego y formaron el
agua y nos dieron vida y por si esto
fuera poco incluimos otro hermoso cuerpo
celeste que coincide qué es
doscientas veces más pequeña que el sol
pero está 400 veces más cerca que el sol
por eso podemos ver unos hermosos
eclipses y eso debe recordarnos siempre
el hermoso entre conexión que comenzó
todo solo planeta
y tierra perdí luna empezando con hace
un millón de años con nuestros primeros
seres vivos su único objetivo absorber
la luz del sol y repartirla eran seres
de luz y comenzó la evolución natural le
llamamos en esta curva la inteligencia
natural un ritmo de expansión y
adaptación casi perfecto y 800 millones
de años después hace unos 70 mil nació
el homo sapiens como una mutación del
lenguaje que nos hizo dejar al chimpancé
atrás y nos trajo a nosotros nos
empezamos a hablar ya interconectar tan
fuerte que creamos sociedades que eran
más poderosas y que por eso
evolucionaron y en algún momento de esta
revolución cognitiva porque podíamos
hablarnos y pensar nos creemos mejores
que la naturaleza y nos inventamos la
agricultura pero lo hicimos por una
buena causa porque si sabíamos sembrar y
cultivar podíamos generar sociedades más
grandes sin tener que ser una especie y
nómada lo hicimos por una buena
intención interconectarnos pero nos
fuimos separando alienando de lo natural
y por si fuera poco creamos las primeras
herramientas en lo que yo llamo la
inteligencia tecnológica que se ha
caracterizado por sus propias
revoluciones quizás el mayor símbolo o
el mayor icono de nuestra revolución
científica es albert eisntein y él decía
en su época que me parece muy acertado
en la nuestra que eficientes amos y
optimizamos tanto los procesos que sería
perfecto que supiéramos cuál es la meta
nuestras herramientas hoy evolucionan
rapidísimo nos evolucionan como la
inteligencia natural ni como la
inteligencia humana evolucionan de
manera exponencial por eso de pronto en
500 años nos fuimos de piedras palos y
lanzas armas nucleares y quizás uno de
los símbolos más interesantes de esta
curva es cuando repasamos los procesos
naturales y le llamamos la
industrialización
quizás el máximo contribuyente de la
desconexión humana de la deshumanización
y si hay un símbolo perfecto de la
industrialización es henry ford trayendo
la producción en masa de automóviles con
una ilusión de progreso con una promesa
de libertad
con una promesa de individualidad yo les
aseguro que henry for me estaba pensando
que lo que iba a pasar después por una
intención de interconectar nos a largas
distancias es encerrar a una especie
social en cajas de metal y vidrio
por eso después tenemos que hacer
campañas de don texto en drive porque
queremos ser sociales aunque estamos
encerrados y creíamos que éramos más
libres y más eficientes pero hoy en
promedio en áreas metropolitanas como la
nuestra se pierden 760 horas hombre al
año en el automóvil
esos son cuatro meses de vacaciones en
jornadas de 8 horas les suena mucho
dividendo a la mitad siguen siendo dos
meses de vacaciones al año quien los
tiene
además el automóvil si comparamos con el
terrorismo desde las torres gemelas el
terrorismo ha matado 67 personas en
promedio anual en china europa y los
eeuu
el automóvil 885.000 30 millones de
personas
y la contaminación del aire otras 7
millones de personas
yo les aseguro que henry ford en su
ideal de interconectarnos no pensó en
esto y por si fuera poco esa misma curva
de herramientas que generamos hoy rebasa
el intelecto humano aquello que nos hizo
mejores que el chimpancé y que nuestros
ancestros que nos destacan como el homo
sapiens hoy se están quedando atrás
estamos viviendo un momento que se
conoce como la singularidad o la cuarta
revolución industrial 4 y r por sus
siglas en inglés en donde las máquinas
tienen muchísimo más poder cognitivo que
nosotros y me preguntan por qué porque
son servidoras y están entre conectadas
y por ejemplo como también tuvimos una
hipótesis y una intención de
interconectar tim berners-lee que nos
diera el internet por allá a finales de
los 80s a todos los noventas cuando
empezamos a interconectar nos empezó con
una buena promesa encontrábamos amigos
familiares que hace mucho que no veíamos
se volvía que padre los tengo aquí en mi
mundo digital me están interconectando
uno a uno y venía en esa emoción de
volver a encontrar a los amigos de la
primaria de la secundaria ya familiares
que hace mucho que no veíamos
y de repente nos empezamos a calificar y
a comparar socialmente y creamos ladies
y lo arts sin pensar que estamos todos
luchando nuestras propias batallas
porque este mundo digital bajo una
promesa de interconexión nos borró las
sensibilidades éticas nos quitó la
limitante natural de hacerle daño a una
persona que estamos viendo a los ojos es
bien fácil dañar a alguien en este mundo
porque no estamos frente a frente y
quizás facebook es el máximo catalizador
de esta falsa idea de interconexión y de
estar cara a cara y hoy los algoritmos
de big data no buscan interconectar nos
busquen interponernos dictaduras buscan
sobreponerse a la creencia de las masas
no sólo manipulando las sino metiendo
las en el riesgo de la irrelevancia y
por si fuera poco preguntas
existenciales que antes le
correspondieran a lautsi o a sócrates
filósofos con alta paciencia hoy están
en manos de inversionistas y de
ingenieros que tienen urgencia por saber
quién somos y que nos pueden vender
scott dialogo en su libro for nos dice
como estos cuatro saben más de nosotros
por likes compras dispositivos móviles y
búsquedas que ni nosotros mismos y por
qué pasó esto
porque creemos que estábamos creciendo
creemos que estamos progresando caímos
en un falso progreso y en una falsa idea
de libertad dice pepe mujica ex
presidente de uruguay que deberíamos de
volver a pensar en lo básico no como
apología de pobreza sino de libertad y
de eso es de lo que se trata porque
nosotros los seres de luz aunque no
todos creemos en dios en los derechos
humanos en el cambio climático todos
creemos en el dinero
y dice yuval no a un autor de tres
libros buenísimos contemporáneos que si
un chimpancé tuviera un papel en mano y
le dijera al otro de los cambios por
esas bananas le diría el otro chimpancé
que cree esto que soy humano
es una realidad nada más nosotros nos
queremos esas historias y sacamos
petróleo debajo de nuestra tierra aunque
caliente nuestro planeta porque tenemos
una idea de crecimiento y bloqueamos el
flujo del agua aunque matemos de 3 a 300
especies de plantas y animales diarios
porque creemos que es más conveniente y
editamos a nuestros alimentos para que
se adapten al cambio que le producimos
al ambiente sin pensar en las
afectaciones a la salud humana ni al
planeta porque nos parece progreso y
como diría martin luther king caemos en
la muerte espiritual cuando comenzamos a
destinar más presupuesto más dinero a
las armas de destrucción en lugar de
apoyo social
y es que nuestros mejores intentos por
tratar de ser mejores por reparar los
problemas que trajeron nuestras propias
tecnologías inventamos esto una
bicicleta que dijimos ahora se va a
movilizar podemos ver scooters hoy por
la calle y bicicletas que podemos rentar
y esto ya sucede en china cementerios de
bicicletas porque parecía un negociazo
era progreso era crecer y ese es el
problema que se tiene ahora y en nuestra
ciudad la última gran inversión que
hicimos es facilitar el flujo de más
automóviles el automóvil en los próximos
20 años se espera que se duplique 8
meses de vacaciones en el transporte de
la casa al trabajo quien los tiene el
automóvil se está volviendo la principal
causa del cambio climático y por si
fuera poco nos volvimos rápidamente la
ciudad más contaminada en temas de
calidad del aire y nuestras mejores
empresas dinamitan nuestros cerros
qué está pasando creímos que vivir era
tener y no
vivir ser
de eso se trata mi padre siempre me dijo
que de esta vida no vamos a llevarnos
nada él me decía que de aquí solo un
puño de tierra y a mí me enseñó entonces
que si no me llevo nada entonces lo dejo
todo
y allí es en donde está el ser en el
interconectarnos y devolvernos la
grandeza humana y para entender la
grandeza de lo humano me fui a conocer a
las secuoyas hace un par de semanas en
california ese soy yo entre los árboles
más grandes del mundo conocía el árbol
más grande del mundo y fue filosófico
totalmente porque no es el más alto ni
es el más ancho es el que tiene más
madera y las secuoyas con 2200 años
crecen casi 100 metros de altura o más y
un árbol que nosotros vemos en la calle
en promedio de 3 metros
necesitas raíces de 3 metros para cuando
venga el aire puede estar bien agarrado
no lo tumbe el tamaño de las raíces de
las secuoyas para 120 metros 100 metros
tendría que ser de centenares de metros
pero sólo miden 3 porque las secuoyas
como pueden ver en la imagen crecen
juntas
se agarran entre sus raíces y si quieres
tumbar una cebolla tienes que tumbar el
bosque y hay experimentos en donde les
inyectan color a sus raíces regresan un
año y el color está en todo el bosque
porque aprendieron a interconectarse
para ser grandes y hoy yo creo que
vivimos esa oportunidad el hueco que
generamos entre la curva de inteligencia
humana de inteligencia natural y el otro
hueco que generamos entre la
inteligencia humana y la tecnológica son
una bellísima oportunidad para tener
esas raíces y enraizarnos y amarrarlos y
poder interconectar nos y regresarnos
esa grandeza la diferencia entre la
inteligencia humana y la inteligencia
natural hoy tiene un hombre es colapso
ambiental o cambio climático está
pasando se están secando los ríos se
están quemando los arrecifes por la
significación estamos perdiendo una
cantidad absurda de especies en fin un
montón de problemas para los cuales
generamos una receta los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible estos nos dicen
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer 17
reglas del juego
para poder pensar en problemas que
tenemos que resolver en todo el planeta
y por si pareciera un tema activista
ambientalista
allí están los negocios de hoy para el
2020 todas las ventas de las cinco
compañías de automóviles más populares
de todos los foros y toyota y volkswagen
que veamos en las calles se van a
dedicar a inversión de impacto un
trillón de dólares sólo en inversión si
nos dedicamos a algunas de las 17 a
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible qué
quiere decir esto que resolver un
problema de esos es tener un mercado del
tamaño del mundo una oportunidad de
hacer dinero y de hacer impacto si no me
creen vean como evolucionado la ciudad
de pontevedra que en el 2007 están en
galicia en el 2007 prohibió el uso de
automóviles pontevedra algo que me
encantó de caminar sobre esa ciudad es
que en lugar de tener una bandera en
alto que diga somos pontevedra tiene el
nombre en el piso recordándonos que la
ciudad está para servir a la gente y no
al revés y en la otra distancia la
inteligencia humana de la tecnológica se
llama disrupción tecnológica lo estamos
viviendo se dice que mi generación es la
generación que va a sufrir por primera
vez busca los efectos del cambio
climático y que es la última que tiene
la oportunidad de hacer algo al respecto
toda esa responsabilidad viene con todas
estas herramientas
si hay 17 objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible al menos hay 17 tecnologías
exponenciales que están a nuestro
servicio que no espero que las vean
todas ahora pero que se lleven el
mensaje de que esto caracteriza la
fusión de la biotecnología nuestro
cuerpo con la info tecnología nuestros
dispositivos nos estamos fusionando con
la tecnología la tecnología está
llegando a nivel cuántico y esa fusión
nos debe de llenar de energía para que
si queremos echar raíces sean
planetarias y nos recuerden que la
tecnología está aquí para hacernos
sentir como las secuoyas
porque si la computación va hacia lo
cuántico hacia la computación de luz y
nosotros somos seres de luz estamos
viviendo nuestro mejor momento nuestra
mejor oportunidad para volver a
interconectar nos
no
como les dije al principio mis padres me
pusieron jesús salvador
y en este año cumplir 33 y yo creo que
puede hacer el último
y en el perderle el miedo a la muerte
uno le pierde el miedo a la vida uno
aprende que hay una gran cantidad de
personas que se mueren con pincel en
mano un corazoncito lleno de color pero
deja sus cuadros en blanco y este
momento que vivimos es para pintar
nuestras mejores obras yo reconozco que
este es el mejor momento para hablar de
equidad de género de igualdad de hombre
y mujer y que estamos migrando del homo
sapiens al homo urbanice y hay que ser
ciudades sostenibles y que nuestras
instituciones públicas nuestros cuerpos
de paz y justicia necesitan más ayuda
que nunca porque son víctimas de su
propia corrupción y si tomo estas tres
de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible y los mezcló con estas tres
herramientas la inteligencia artificial
que hoy está en todas partes la
computación cuántica o en la nube que
también nos ayude interconectarnos y
block change quizás la mejor herramienta
para acabar con sistemas corruptos
combino tareas con herramientas y
tenemos propósitos
eso eso es existe una empresa que
esperaba encontrar un crecimiento
económico a partir de un crecimiento con
significado que nos hace saber que lo
que nos toca es contribuir a la mejora
de las ciudades ya tener un mejor futuro
en las zonas en donde vivimos porque
sólo así creciendo con significado
viviremos el máximo potencial de la
cuarta revolución industrial porque así
como llegó la cuarta vendrá la quinta y
yo espero que se la llevamos por dentro
y no por fuera que nos recordemos que es
momento de pensar con el corazón y de
sentir con la cabeza o como diría
eduardo galiano de poner un ojo al
telescopio que nos permita ver el
planeta y otro al microscopio que
estamos haciendo nosotros
yo pienso que si hoy viviera john
f.kennedy nos diría no pienses que puede
hacer tu planeta por ti piensa qué
puedes hacer tú por tu planeta
es momento de pensar que nuestras
herramientas son parte de nosotros y de
darnos cuenta que la crisis que vivimos
no es tecnológica no es económica y no
es ambiental es espiritual se nos olvidó
que espiritualidad es celebrar la
interconexión naturaleza tecnología y
personas porque créanme nosotros somos
naturaleza y nuestras herramientas
también y cuando lo entendemos y
trabajamos por ello estamos creciendo en
un verdadero crecer
en crecer que nos lleva del pertenecer
al verdadero pertenecer un crecer que se
vuelve un acto de amor y cuando crecer
es un acto de amor uno se pone a hacer
el ramadán en agradecimiento radical
no le canta a su niña una canción
hermosa de calamaro que dice te quiero y
sé que me esperan más aeropuertos pero
primero te quiero igual
y yo sé que mi niña entiende que papá
podrá subirse a un avión pero va a
regresar a casa
y que papá está viviendo en sus máximos
temores y sus máximas pasiones al mismo
tiempo pero que lo está haciendo para
reparar un poco el mundo que le pedí
prestado
y ya sabe que papas reconocen sus
dispositivos y en todos esos viajes la
oportunidad de sentirse en casa en
cualquier parte del mundo y de ver en la
disrupción tecnológica una oportunidad
para empoderarnos y resolver esos
problemas globales esa diversidad que
está ahí para inspirarnos y que hoy es
momento de ser más culturas y ser más
más tradiciones
ser más conocimiento y ser más
experiencias y ser más tiempo de ser más
yo
de servir
si todos supiéramos servir yo podría
regresar a casa con la sola esperanza de
levantarme pero al sol
y disfrutar de una taza de café